the vanilla extract oftentimes is beaver
butt juice
and there's another word for it is he
being serious
yeah that's true
is there a connection between the
science of food addiction and sorcery
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live today we are going
to talk about the science of food
addiction
yeah
you guys are ready to do this oh yeah i
think if you've got questions you're
going to have some answers today from a
biblical perspective and uh we've been
blessed to have eric wilson on our show
it's good to be here yet again he's
basically like family yeah yes so
welcome back and uh if you guys missed
his previous show you'll have to check
it out what do we talk about in the
previous the last one was called
appetite satan's strongest hold upon man
if you haven't watched that you should
go and watch that because it'll make a
lot of sense in today's talk yeah this
they dovetail together the first one
lays a foundation spiritually that
really
it really is eye-opening all right so
i'm kind of very curious because you
know there's a few things that are very
hard to talk about right
food don't touch my plate right another
one music don't talk about my music
that's true so these two things are are
a difficult thing to understand but um
in today's modern world there is
actually a lot of science
that gets poured into
crazy simple things so we're gonna
explore some of those things today and
uh thank you guys for stopping by we
hope you're blessed by today's talk amen
so take it away eric how how are you
going to introduce this well it's good
to be here again with everyone and i
want to encourage all of our brothers
and sisters out there that are watching
we thank you for your support for the
show here for little light studios
we're going to take a look at this and
we're we're sharing this because it's
something that i battled with
in our last program where we did the
you know the stronghold of appetite most
people think if you've got a problem
with appetite we talked about obesity we
talked about one of the things that
shocked me was according to the cdc
of all
adults 20 years and older in america are
overbeats are overweight wow or they're
obese and overweight
i remember the first time i went to the
doctor and i always it was that kid that
could just eat anything and never gained
a pound until i was 30. and then i can
remember the first time that the doctor
weighed me and was like so you're
slightly overweight you know i was like
what
i am
so for me and um i'm encouraging our
friends our brothers and sisters
it shocked me because i've battled with
appetite i shouldn't say have
i'm done battling with it but praise god
i battled with that for most of my life
from age 12 until in my 30s i battled
with appetite actually into my 40s
and i never was overweight yeah i was
going to say i've seen old footage of
you and stuff and the dragon revealed
check out that but uh you never looked
overweight no i was never overweight but
i had an addiction to food and i
couldn't stop it
and so
when we look at appetite it's just it
doesn't mean just simply overweight or
obese or fat or anything it just means
there is a
there's something that the enemy is has
found a way to use inside of man and
we're going to look because science
actually is showing this now mm-hmm so
um
there's a it's good that there's a
standard because our bodies our
individual bodies are not a good
barometer that's right the barometer is
principles and also your habits that's
right take a look at that that's right
we would like to thank all of you who
support this ministry through your
donations and by buying merch from
lightwear.shop
we cannot do this without you and if you
send in your pictures we will put you on
the show
in our last message we showed how
babylon
as well as sodom and gomorrah as well as
the days of noah
all of those the foundation for their
sins was found in appetite
the gratification of unnatural appetite
led to the sins that caused the
destruction of sodom and gomorrah
god ascribes the fall of babylon also to
her gluttony and drunkenness
indulgence of appetite and passion was
the foundation of all their sins
and if you want references on this go
back and watch our earlier program on
the stronghold of satan and appetite
there's so much in there that we showed
from scripture that will really
encourage you
so sodom and gomorrah even the days of
noah sodom and gomorrah esau all those
examples and even babylon
it was gluttony and drunkenness
we're going to take a look here at some
video clips that show how self-indulgent
and how appetite has such a stronghold
on our our culture our world today wow
we're seeing eating competitions let me
pause that for a moment when you look at
these eating competitions
i watched these people eating and i
thought
that hurts my stomach i mean i could
overeat back before the lord set me free
i could overeat easily
but there was a point where it hurt so
bad that you just had to go i don't care
how good it tastes i don't want to eat
anymore
these guys are eating like two and three
entire pizzas i know and they're doing
it fast isn't your stomach about the
size of both of your fists together i
don't know how do you see i think that's
kind of the rule of thumb is like it's
generally about the size of that i
thought it was just one fist actually
but have you seen videos of what it
looks like on the inside of competition
eaters and how the stomach can stretch
and push your intestines up and it's
like this whole thing we should include
that i'll try to find it okay if you can
that would be good seven consecutive
time champion joey chestnut set a world
record eating 69 hot dogs in 10 minutes
to put in perspective what 69 hot dogs
looks like inside a human body we
brought in a one-of-a-kind
anthropomorphic dummy complete with a
hot dog stuff
oh a human can stomach on average about
one liter of food before the nausea
reflex kicks in signaling us to stop
eating but competitive eaters train
their bodies to ignore this reflex
as a result their stomachs are capable
of holding down
four plus liters of food a capacity more
than four times greater than the average
stomach
when you eat so many hot dogs your
stomach expands and actually does push
all of your organs out of the way
this is 69 hot dog buns 69 hot dogs and
over two quarts of water this is what it
looks like inside the human body do you
know what is amazing to me though is
any time that i have yielded the
appetite and overeating i can i can tell
because it affects the way i feel
emotionally and it affects the way i
think you sit down and eat a huge meal
you don't want to go read your bible
afterwards yeah i mean you don't you can
sit down
yeah you can sit and watch tv and go oh
that's fine
thanksgiving dinner and i'm kicked back
going oh i don't want to move i overeat
god does not want us to get to that
point you never imagined jesus going oh
and he's burping and you know i ate too
much he never did that
he wants our minds to be clear so if my
if my stomach is affecting the way that
i think
then i've got to bring the stomach into
subjection to the mind of christ
now this next video
was startling this video is a it's one
of a couple of different restaurants
that are like burger restaurants
and their entire goal there is to make
you buy everything that's not healthy
they don't even sell healthy stuff in
these places but listen to what they say
look at the tagline here
chase worth dying for wow i mean it's
interesting that they even just put that
on there and is she a nurse yeah yeah
now this is what caught me
after our last program we talked we
showed from the bible the the connection
between
immorality and sensuality and appetite
and here this restaurant
yeah that's what they're doing
whoa
nobody can eat that
and they dress like nurses
sin city yeah they're just open about
that
like literally people like love it
and it
okay it's in sin city and it is
definitely gluttonous and
yeah they're dressed like nurses but
their cleavage is all popping out so
it's yeah this century it's like a
it's like a heart attack hooters yeah
yeah literally i feel like
what this bot our bodies can take is
like a sign of god's grace amen oh we
can keep doing all these things and
still live amen
okay look what revelation says about
babylon whose
foundation of her sins was gluttony and
drunkenness
it says alas alas that great city that
was clothed in fine lemon and purple and
scarlet and decked with gold and
precious stones and pearls
for in one hour so great riches is come
to naught
for thy merchants pay attention to that
word thy merchants were the great men of
the earth and by thy sorceries were all
nations deceived okay now it's very
interesting yes now it's going to get in
so the merchants you said notice that
because you're talking about like the
people who are selling all this food and
stuff right and
the wealthies of the wealthy are yeah
these these companies that our own and
all these
food companies who don't even eat their
own food right
this is the word sorceries that's used
there in that text in revelation
in the greek it's 53 31 and it comes
from 53 32. the greek word is pharmakia
that's where we get our word pharmacy
from
or pharmacist but the greek word this is
the definition it means medication
magic
spell giving
witchcraft a potion a druggist a
poisoner or a magician
that's that's in the king james bible
that's the word of god
so by thy sorceries
were all
nations deceived
so satan is going to use sorcery to
deceive the world and i've heard videos
before where people say well it's the
pharmaceutical companies or it's the the
drug companies
but you know what satan has figured out
how he can use drugs to deceive everyone
and instead of him having to get us to
smoke marijuana or drink alcohol or use
cocaine he has learned how to use the
chemicals within the human body to cause
us to be deceived
this is from a book called councils on
diets and foods i recommend this book to
everybody that's interested in victory
over appetite
councils on diets and foods page 150
satan is constantly on the alert to
bring the race fully under his control
his dominion
his strongest hold on man is through
appetite
and this he seeks to stimulate in every
possible way
all unnatural excitements that means
stimulants
are harmful and they cultivate the
desire for liquor
all unnatural stimulants it makes sense
i mean if satan wants to get
the most people he can get everybody has
to eat
so it's like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
attack the thing that they need
breathing and eating yeah so i'm
assuming since
um different food combinations once in
the stomach turn into liquor that the
desire of liquor is not necessarily
drinking yes ma'am amen
i'm so glad you brought that up that's
exactly right because if you if you have
poor food combining like you're eating
different kinds of food that shouldn't
be mixed together
some foods require a certain enzyme to
digest other foods require a different
enzyme to digest and if you mix those
two foods together
it's difficult for the stomach and
actually can cause fermentation in the
stomach overeating will cause
fermentation i heard something about
that before like well bread has yeast in
it and i heard somebody said that
you can fail a breathalyzer if you eat a
certain kind of bread or something i
haven't heard that on that but one thing
my wife did find
because she's been in education she was
in public education in school systems
for almost 20 years she said most of the
teachers would come in and they would
say like especially grades kindergarten
through fourth grade she said the kids
were acting crazy for the first half of
the day
and she said they found out why because
when you take milk and sugar and mix it
together in the acid in the stomach it
forms alcohol
so all the cocoa pebbles and fruit loops
and milk and
two hours later the kids are buzzing
this is interesting this is scientific
america and you look at that plate that
they've got on the front of the cover
with pizza and burgers and fries and
onion rings all of that stuff you know
full of grease full of salt
and the cover says gluttony are we
addicted to eating eating
and we're going to look at just some of
these are just pictures
this is a a recent one from newsweek
called toxic food and on the front label
it says warning ultra processed food
raises the risk of diabetes of cancer of
heart disease obesity and of dying of
covid19 because your
immunity is messed up that's exactly
right
so this is not we don't have to go to
the bible to find this god's word is
true but now the rocks are crying out
because people are like i don't want to
hear that part of the bible you know
don't talk to me about that i'll skip
over that chapter and god's like i'm
going to put it in newsweek so you'll
hear
now it said all unnatural excitements
stimulants
this is the number one
excitement excitotoxin in the world it's
called msg monosodium glutamate
i never used to worry about it and still
i started until i started sensing
the effect it was having on me and i'll
give you a couple of examples i used to
work
for a home security company where we did
uh pre-wires and houses for security
systems and cameras
and i was outside in the heat all day
long and my my best friend and i worked
in the band together because we had
teams
and i would always take a big huge
64-ounce thing of like welch's 100 pure
grape juice with me during the day so in
case my blood sugar got low i didn't
want to eat in between meals i would
just drink some juice
well i started noticing even though it
was a hundred percent natural grape
juice i started noticing that i would
take a drink of it and the one i was
getting was uh
it was grape and black cherry is my
favorite it was like i loved it but i
would take a drink of it eight ounces of
it and put it down
five minutes later i was opening back up
drinking it again and i found myself
going through one or two of those a day
wow and i it's like i couldn't and it
was the taste
and then one day i flipped it over just
out of curiosity and looked at the
ingredients and it said flavors well it
said 100 pure grape juice you know
concentrate water
natural flavors and i was like what does
that mean i mean what is it it's grape
juice what do you have to add flavors to
it well then i found out
i was looking through a book at the
health food store that was
specifically on all the ingredients the
ingredients that you can't pronounce and
you go i don't even know what that is it
tells what they are
natural flavors it said more than 90
percent of the time it's msg
it's a
a flavor enhancer that they put into
that so that you keep drinking because
the more you drink the more you eat the
more you buy
originally monosodium glutamate was uh
developed by uh an asian man i don't
remember if he was chinese or japanese
but he had developed it to make the
rations for the troops in the military
tastes better because they were having a
hard time getting their military to eat
the rations um so he made this and all
of a sudden everybody was like i love
these rations
and he didn't know the damage that it
would do and i know there's debates
about it but look
if you're if you want to know the truth
you'll know the truth when you hear it
monosodium glutamate not only destroys
the brain nerves it corrupts the brain
nerves it creates tons of free radicals
inside the brain and it also destroys
the liver
there's a doctor named dr russell
blaylock that has done some unbelievable
research on this he wrote a book years
ago called
excitotoxins the taste that kills but
he's also available you can watch some
of his powerful documentaries on youtube
for free you'd actually found out
by calling a company ice cream company
that yes you want to tell that real
quick well
there was a uh a vegan a non-dairy ice
cream that i and my family loved we had
used it for years
it was called rice stream and i mean
loved it
and
one day i had this particular kind they
used to make it was like a little like
oatmeal cream pie ice cream with ice
cream in the middle i like those but i
could buy one of them and it was enough
one day i went to get one and i ate it
on the way home
before i got home i found myself turning
around to go back to the grocery store
to buy another one oh wow now i'm not
kidding
i went back three times on that one trip
home to get another one
and i got home and it was like i knew
something was not right i mean i was
like god forgive me what's wrong with me
and i flipped it over and before they
had never put that word natural flavors
but now the word natural flavors was
there so i called image foods to find
out what's in the natural flavors and
the lady was really polite she said it's
proprietary you know we can't give
everybody what our special makes our
flavors so good
and i i was patient but i said ma'am i
said we've got a member of my family
that
has health problems when it comes to msg
i said is the natural flavors msg and
she said no
i said is it
free glutamate or any form of free-form
glutamic acid and she got really quiet
and she said sir if that's a problem for
someone in your family i would encourage
you to look for another vegan ice cream
wow so even though it wasn't msg
it was a free form glutamic acid or
glutamate which is the same thing
yeah and it's just sad that we live in a
world that they can't just like outright
this is what we're doing it's like
buried in all this
terminology legal
schmiegel
well you remember the merchants of this
earth are waxed rich through the
abundance
they're making money because they're
selling food because it tastes
yeah wow now let's look at this back a
number of years ago i don't remember if
the trade name or whatever ran out the
legality with that but they were able to
start i think they've got almost 300
different names now that they can name
msg
it doesn't have to say msg on it i'm
just going to list a couple of the names
you can do your own research online
these are some of the common names
glutamic acid
glutamate
monopotassium glutamate
calcium glutamate
yeast extract oh who would you know
what is that like are we talking like uh
brewer's ease kind of thing no it's
yeast extract you'll look on some of the
ingredients in your food and you'll see
yeast extract it's msg
so i have a question can a company put
no msg on their packaging and still have
these in it yes
so they're different forms of msg
no it's it's still
msg but they can call it
uh glutamate is a natural occurring
molecule in different types of food the
presence how much glutamate is there is
what makes it
dangerous or not dangerous because the
way god designed food the glutamate
wasn't an issue because there were other
things in there that canceled out the
negatives or enhance the positives
but what they have found is they can go
in and i'll i'll give an example
i used to work at a health food store
and the the man that did the buying for
the food he told me one time he said
eric he said this one is like the number
one if you have somebody comes in you
know they're sick this is the organic
food you want to sell to them from this
company and i said well how about this
one this one says organic he said eric
he said if you'll look in the fine print
from our sellers our suppliers
they will say and this is just an
example
if it says 100 organic apple juice
only 70 of the apples in there have to
be organic for them to label the whole
bottle organically the other 30 could
have come from pesticide city
but they could still label it as being
organic so that's how twisted and messed
up our world has begun so with msg it's
the same way
but let me just show you some of the
names the common names
yeast extract
hydrogenized protein
calcium caseinate
there's all kinds of people we buy vegan
cheese or non-dairy cheese if it has
casonate in it
it's got msg
sodium casonate
autolyzed yeast gelatin
textured protein
soy protein isolate or whey protein
concentrate and these are just a few of
the names
and it's not something to be scared of
but what i found was when my wife and i
first started looking at this
it made us nervous because we were kind
of angry because we're like man i don't
have time to look at the ingredients
list on everything
but then we watched the documentary
called um what the hell no it was uh
forks overnight no hold on a second
secrets um secrets something
the name will come back to me or mikey
if you want to look it up if you get a
chance um
secret ingredients that's the name of
the documentary i would what i would
recommend that to every person that's
watching it's called secret ingredients
they went through and they showed a
family that had i don't remember 27
chronic illnesses in this one family
including their children children little
boys that had chronic illnesses
and the doctors couldn't figure out any
of the problems what was causing it the
wife had problems the
father had problems
then she started doing research on
pesticides and gmo food and
msg they got rid of all the gmo foods
all the pesticides in their food and all
the msg every one of the problems were
gone in a year and a half every one of
the problems
cancer
all kinds of health issues that were
they all disappeared all the children
all their health issues disappeared
and i was like okay this is worth this
to me i don't have time to read the
ingredients then something's wrong with
me
i was thinking about how you're saying
the merchants are selling
or the merchants sell clearly and it's
sorcery or pharmakia
and people they
they what do they call it uh it's like
therapeutic eating or whatever like the
when they're depressed they eat
yeah comfort food that's clearly showing
you that
there's something in this food that can
medicate you in some way like that's
what the the definition of pharmakeia
was medicine or whatever so yes that
makes sense and i think the next slide
or two it's going to show some of that
let me just give you a couple of
examples how many people have ever
bought doritos before and you couldn't
finish i mean you couldn't stop yourself
from eating the whole thing of course or
pringles i mean like a pringles i mean
you know you take one if i'm going to
get 10. well they advertise that once
you've popped you can't stop yeah
well there's a reason why
look in doritos right there it is
monosodium glutamate
then you've also got natural and
artificial flavors you've got sodium
casonate i didn't even highlight those
yellow five wow i mean
there's just some red 40.
that's the inside joke from the last
episode check it out yeah that's the red
that you're not supposed to eat yeah oh
wow if it's artificial
like why would they even do that on a
yellow chip like how do you need to put
something red in there yeah well you
gotta think about this if it's
artificial
god never intended us to eat it he gave
us food that he created to eat he didn't
say oh yeah you can make a i mean like
you're gonna go in a lab with some
chemicals and and
call that food this one was from a
chicken vegetable flavor and this one
was scary too look at this
monosodium glutamate hydro
hydrolyzed corn and soy protein
autolyze yeast extract natural and
artificial flavor
autolyze
taroula yeast extract
i think it's interesting like in
california you always see these labels
that say like known to cause cancer in
california or something only california
but it's like on anything like water
hose or a thermos or whatever yep i just
think it's funny too that we put on
their natural and artificial flavoring i
mean why don't you just put stuff yeah
there's stuff in this yeah yeah it's
like that says nothing about products
it's scary it's scary i mean who would
think soy protein is going to be
anything bad you know except for the
fact that almost all soy is gmo that's
just true it's one of the highest
we're at such a weird place right now i
bet they could make a marketing out of
this like they could joke they could
highlight all the worst chemicals in
there and be like enjoy your
cancer-causing chemicals and people like
oh that's funny
i know like they wouldn't really do that
yeah
it's sad it's sad
now we're gonna look at a video and this
is this is very interesting and the lady
that did this video she's not as far as
i know a scientist it's not some
renowned you know harvard medical school
but i did research and found everything
that she talked about from other
scientists she's 100 on
listen to what she's going to say
that red and yellow sleeve that certain
flavor in the oil that you can't quite
put your finger on that one-two combo
punch of sugar and salt what exactly is
it that makes mcdonald's fry so
perfectly craveable so addictively
munchable time after time visit after
visit we found out
so it's combination of stuff there is
and it it's gonna get more watch this
even without msg they know how to create
an addiction through taste wow
sugar and salt are two of the most
addictive foods in the world sugar has
even been likened to a drug dietitian
cassie bjork told healthline research
shows that sugar can be even more
addicting than cocaine sugar activates
the opiate receptors in our brain and
affects the reward center which leads to
compulsive behavior despite the negative
consequences like weight gain headaches
hormone imbalances and more that helps
explain why the fries are so addicting
mcdonald's coats their fries in dextrose
a form of sugar to make them more
consistent in their golden brown
appearance and then pounds them with
salt when they are pulled from the fryer
when salt and sugar are combined in this
sort of balanced equilibrium the brain
floods with dopamine the
neurotransmitter that produces feelings
of pleasure and our willpower can't hope
to compete
i guess that's another thing to remember
is that not all sugar is sweet
you know that's why you're not tasting
sweetness on the fry but it's still the
chemical composition that's right sugar
and almost almost all fast foods and
this is just the fast foods
they have found that there is an exact
ratio of sugar salt and fat oil that if
they use that ratio it releases dopamine
in the human brain and dopamine is a
feel good hormone it's addictive people
want that you can go on youtube and find
out how to do dopamine dopamine detoxes
you know to get that junk out of your
body where you've overloaded on it
these these fry i don't know what
they're made of i mean i guess they're
made out of potato but
if they go cold they just taste horrible
and you can't rewarm them yeah
yeah but in that moment they're just so
good and they talk about that i don't
know if we included that but this video
talks about how long that lasts
remember that natural beef flavoring
well there's another weird side effect
of it when the ingredients break down
during the cooking process they create
naturally occurring monosodium glutamate
or msg there have been a lot of rumors
about msg that have been debunked over
the years but researchers have
discovered one actual property of msg it
interferes with the satiation mechanism
in our brains and has been proven in
some studies to increase overall food
intake in laboratory animals that means
when you start eating fries you may not
be able to stop stuffing your face it's
not your fault it's science
so so it's basically shutting off the
mechanism that that your body has a
natural way to say i'm full to say
satiation yeah it means i'm full i feel
satisfied yeah and so all of a sudden
it's like block that thing and it's just
you just keep intaking intake it
chemically
turns that off so you keep eating so the
more you eat the more you buy it's about
money and this is where it's sad it's
sad that we live in a world where we
have huge companies like this that don't
say how can i produce something that is
good for the person or whatever it's
literally like we don't care what this
is actually doing to you as long as you
buy more of it that's the love of money
is the root of all evil because even the
chemicals that they put in these foods
they just make them last longer on the
shelf so they have a longer shelf life
to be bought it's all about money
we don't care about what those chemicals
do to the person's body just as long as
we can sell it for longer and i mean if
there is 200 names for msg and they're
all hidden under whatever that means
that somebody took them to court
and in that court system they found a
way to work around that exactly right
now this is the thing and this is i want
to encourage people
it's not just fast foods
remember what that warning label said
and what that woman is processed heavily
processed so the the more that we can
eat stuff that's not already in a box or
in a can or it's already been processed
the more that we can make food the way
our grandparents did my wife told me
that she said eric she said
instead of us buying beans in a can i
know it's faster
if i know i'm gonna eat beans for that
week let's put a crock pot on and we'll
have beans for the whole week you know
you can get them whenever you want them
but we're making them at the house it's
just beans and i added the salt i know
what's in the food that's good so we're
learning how to just go in and eat the
way our grandparents did
when you go into a grocery store i
remember learning about how
strategically each aisle is laid out and
how the things that are the hardest to
get are out on this edges they put the
milk in the back because they know that
everybody's going to come
through there to get the milk and i mean
it's like there's so much thought that
goes into this
that we're literally going through a
gauntlet to try and like you know
survive it's nuts and then you're in the
aisle and there's all these candy while
you're sitting there waiting like oh
those m m's right there i heard i heard
one man one time that was the science
and the researcher and he said something
he said when you go into the grocery
store and you go through the produce
aisle to get to everything else he said
once you go through the produce aisle he
said you've lost almost every bit of
your nutrition
he said once you step out of the produce
like i'll give you an example like a
salad
people sometimes will make a salad for
tomorrow when you cut vegetables up
you've got two hours and they lose
eighty-five percent of their vitamins
amount two hours once they're sliced
so it's like you know when we're making
salads now i make the salad when i'm
about to eat it right because now they
got the bags of salad in the box if it's
been sliced and cut there's there's no
vitamins and minerals almost left 85
percent of them are gone within two
hours
so i don't know that but it makes the
difference because you talked about
people that have got great health they
know that and they eat simply they eat
the things and that's got the most
nutrients the most nutrient dense foods
and then this and then the same with
cooked vegetables too like there's a
certain point where you can like steam
them and stuff but once you cook them
they just turn to sugar starch
you lose a lot of the vitamins and
minerals yeah
so let's go and look at
another part of this clip from the
earliest days of mcdonald's way back
when it was a barbecue restaurant run by
the actual mcdonald brothers fries were
on the menu and that helps explain how
mcdonald's has managed to make such
delicious fries when you've been doing
something for the better part of a
century you get really good at it
i didn't include the clip and i wish i
had
they actually talk about something
that originally mcdonald's they did
something to make their fries have a
distinctive flavor
they added oil
but to the oil they mixed in beef talon
or beef tallow
it gave it a beef flavor because it was
beef that was being added well that
became a problem because people found
out so they took away the beef tallow
and they put in
just the oil but they added a
synthetic
beef flavor
which has a portion some portion of beef
still in it so the fries themselves they
say we can't tell you these are
vegetarian or vegan wow
so
it's
not saying that you're a sinner if
you're eating
beef i mean obviously that's not a sin
in the bible is it healthy for you
that's up for you to decide
now this was a clip from 60 minutes and
this was uh this was a few minutes in
length but it's powerful listen to what
he says
as the thanksgiving weekend comes to a
close you may feel as overstuffed as
that turkey you ate
and if you're overweight and the chances
are you are it's probably because you
eat too much too much of the wrong stuff
most of the wrong stuff we eat comes in
a bottle a can or a box food that's been
processed much of that food has been
flavored
the flavoring industry is the enabler of
the food processing business which
depends on it to create a craving for
everything from soda pop to chicken soup
it is willy wonka and his chocolate
factory as a multi-billion dollar
industry an industry cloaked in secrecy
but recently juvederm the largest
flavoring company in the world
allowed us in to see them work their
magic
secrecy and magic yeah literally
billions of dollars that's interesting
and he used the word magic
and billions yeah i mean we just talked
about the merchants of the earth were
wax rhythms with the abundance of your
delicacies and the sorcery magic yeah
because it's not for the benefit of you
it's for the benefit of them that's
right there's a lot of secrecy involved
in your profession correct our
intellectual property are our formulas
without that we have nothing so there's
a lot of secrecy you really don't want
anyone to know yeah i i actually um did
some video work for a cracker company i
won't tell which one but i mean i had to
sign away all kinds of disclosures there
was only certain places that they would
actually let me go in and video i could
not video the actual process of of where
the stuff was i could only see it being
put in the boxes and i mean it was just
like wow it was pretty pretty intense
and it really made you think like and
this particular company was a vegan
gluten-free cracker that was like
literally uh sold as a very very healthy
alternative but nobody knew what was in
it because i can't tell you i'll tell
you
i worked in a slaughterhouse for a short
few months i didn't stay too long but
uh i was in the sausage room and i'm
standing on top of this giant
vat with this corkscrew going and i had
to dump these powders and stuff in there
and he would tell me you know fill up
this much these buckets of powder and
there was a pink one and to this day i
still can't find what he called it i
don't know what it was really called but
he called it curavus it was pink
and he said don't breathe that it'll
kill you
he threw some cuss words in there but he
said he was very serious don't breathe
don't breathe we're gonna feed it to
people right yeah and you're just
dumping it in there and i'm thinking of
some kind of preservative probably
that's terrifying wow that company
doesn't exist anymore if somebody you
know i'm a vegetarian for health reasons
if somebody is going to eat meat though
i'm going to tell you the best thing
that you can do for yourself and for
your family is go buy it grass-fed
organic no pesticides no hormones
injected don't buy the stuff at the
grocery store it's terrible even with
that you have a pesticide farm and a
natural farm right next to each other i
know there's cross-country
i know but i'm just i'm saying that
do the best you can but you should also
go and tour a slaughterhouse and some
other things that would really probably
cure you of most of that well there's
another documentary that i would
encourage people to watch don't watch it
um with your little children though it's
called food inc
it is the most i watched it with my two
children when they were like in their
teens and both of them were just like
dad i mean they showed what happens to
where we get that food in all different
kinds of food not just meat yeah it's
called food inc i've seen machines just
like come up around the cow's head and
spit them all around and crazy it's sad
it's sad
now he's going to go in and he's going
to talk with one of the
flavor
scientists that helped to develop these
different flavors and listen to what she
says i have butyric acid artificial and
then i have butyric acid natural all
flavors are combinations of chemicals
artificial flavors are largely man-made
natural flavors come from nature but not
necessarily from what the label implies
for example strawberry creations
strawberry and vanilla flavor can come
from the gland in a beaver's backside
so what we do is just uh manipulate them
and create with them
and give the impression of
you know papaya or the strawberry a
beaver yes
so if it says natural strawberry
flavoring it may be from a beaver's
bottom
from a strawberry i've heard of this i
recently
brought this to the attention of
brittany that there's
the vanilla extract oftentimes this
beaver butt juice i didn't know that are
you kidding me
and there's another word for it is he
being serious no it's yeah that's true
but this is just really eye-opening i
need you to send that to me i need to
know that because we use vanilla
organic and i'm like i want an organic
beaver organic beaver i would like to
know who who first discovered that right
yeah
this animal has some drunk
[Music]
um peppermints yeah the red and white
peppermints it's actually from a beetle
they crush it and it has a red dye that
comes yeah
oh right here have you heard of that
before no i feel like we need to have a
bunch of articles underneath this stuff
yeah there should be some serious
sources of questions excited but this is
really eye-opening when you see like you
buy stuff from a store food you consume
it and you don't think about there's
some scientists walking around in a lab
creating your food man that's straight
sorcery like we're saying yes
it is scary
listen as she goes on
we're eating fat on fat on sugar on fat
with flavor and much of what we're
eating with these flavors you have to
ask yourself
is it really food
dr david kessler is the former head of
the fda he is dr no
he's bent on getting america to kick its
bad habits
we're living in a food carnival these
flavors are so stimulating they hijack
our brain kessler believes flavorists
are accomplices the hired guns of the
food industry they make food
super palatable what's wrong with that
do we want the richness of good taste of
course food has to be pleasurable it has
to be desirable
but look around morley look around this
country and what do you see
ask the rest of the world how they view
americans and they will say we don't
want
to look like them
wow
that's the former head of the fda yeah
really that there's got to be this crazy
correlation between the food and drug
administration and it's like they're the
ones that are like green lighting a lot
of this stuff but they're the ones that
are giving you the medicines to fix it
so the fact that that that entity is in
bed with both sides is is a difficult
one for me
thinking about how much the world's
changed in 200 300 years or something
like like he said our brains have been
hijacked by food but not also not just
food video games social media television
and we're just like staring at these
glowing screens while we're eating this
addictive food our brains are just
completely hijacked
and satan knows if he can control the
brain the mind that's the only avenue
through which god can reach us
so if he can destroy the mind through
any of those he destroys god's
opportunity to save and set us free
now this is what mikey was bringing up
and candy touched on this too you know
the bible says we are fearfully and
wonderfully made we have endorphins that
are released inside of our body and our
glands we have pheromones and pheromones
are the smell that comes off our body
based on
what's happening in the mind
especially like
if there's potential for
male and female in a reaction there's
certain smells that the body releases to
let the other person know
animals especially mammals do this all
the time it's a smell that lets another
person know hey i'm interested wow
but those aren't the ones we're focusing
on
we're focusing on the dopamine and the
oxytocin the dopamine is a
it's a pleasure
but it's also a safety it's a feeling of
security and pleasure and accomplishment
that is what they were talking about
about the dopamine receptors and the
opiate receptors when dopamine is
released through the food it causes you
to feel good eating the food and that's
why we keep getting another chip that's
why we keep getting another fry or we
keep getting another drink of that you
know natural flavors juice
because it releases a chemical inside
and as it's releasing those chemicals
i'm yielding to intemperance
and intemperance is the foundation of
almost every other sin
so satan says if i can take that out if
i can control that part of them the rest
of the sins become easy
i know for myself that if in my past if
i had overeaten it was easier to yield
to other sins
if if
if i've overeaten it was easier to say
i'm just going to compromise and watch
this movie i know it's rated r but it's
okay
whereas if i was on a
a more careful diet or i was you know
restraining myself from not overeating i
could look at that and i could see it
with reason through the spirit of god
and say i don't want to watch that
so if i could say if i can stand my
ground on what's necessary it'll be
easier for us to stand on the word of
god with any other temptation that comes
well i was just thinking you know it is
a god-made thing and it's not
bad it's just the way it's being
triggered and and
when i get to share the gospel with
people and i can tell that they're
receptive to it man like i'm inside i'm
getting excited i'm rejoicing and then
when it happens i'm like dude that i
want to do that again like that's
addictive you know and it talks about
the angels rejoicing when one repented
sinner and i think that that's the type
of things that god put us put in us like
when you give your wife a flower and you
see or shine or whatever you're like oh
i don't want to do that again you know
amen well that's god's natural way for
to get us to to to do that action again
i mean he gave us natural pleasure
that when we eat hey that was a good
thing do that again and it's just been
hijacked and changed and stuff i mean
eating is such an intimate part of
humanity that this is just the devil
twisting what god has naturally built up
yeah yeah so
i'm glad you brought that up mike you
know the chemicals in there the dopamine
the oxytocin the endorphins the
pheromones those were created by our
savior by our god
but satan has perverted them
and that's what he does with everything
he takes something that's right and he
twists it so that it's not right anymore
so this is helping us to understand how
he's doing that now when i drive by a
fast food restaurant like 10 years ago
it was a temptation i was like man you
know those fries smell good and he was
like well i remember what those tasted
like now it's like there's not there's
like nothing there i'm just like it's
dead
it's helped me to be able to say i'm not
going to do that because i know i know
now what's what's happening there and i
know what satan's trying to do through
those things to me
so you can't counter it eat some fries
and eat a bowl of salad no
it's not that you don't you don't
balance the good and evil god's like i
want it all to be good
yin yang diet here
so we were told you know about babylon
for thy merchants were the great men of
the earth your merchants and we just
heard it was billions of dollars just in
the flavoring industry
and by thy sorceries were all nations
deceived
and this is a a picture of
representing you know childhood obesity
and this this was scary to me because
over 20 percent i think it was 21
of children under 12 years old now are
obese in america and it's interesting
when you go to restaurants and stuff and
you look at the children's menu what is
on the children's menu
it is this
i mean that's literally what like they
only eat burgers fries and mac and
cheese
every restaurant doesn't matter if
you're at a mexican restaurant they'll
serve you there actually broccoli in
there yeah you know and it's it's sad
because the kids don't they can't choose
at this point you know they're eating
with their families feeding them or with
what tastes good to them they don't have
a logical way to say i should really eat
something that's good for my body you
know
you know and as they grow up that
affects us
i mean i grew up eating uh
biscuits and gravy i mean that was just
my grandmother made us biscuits that's
the most unhealthy thing in the world
it's got crisco in there and you know
buttermilk and you know sugar and salt
and oil and it wasn't good for me
um
we it's harder to to unlearn those
things so if we can start even even at
my age i'm young compared to what we're
going to be in heaven
so if i can make changes now they last
and if we can raise our children and
encourage people don't beat them down if
you see them doing something wrong
encourage them say hey try this and just
be
show what god's way will do in your life
so that other people will desire it
now
we're going to look at a different part
of appetite for a few minutes
most people when they think about
appetite they think about obesity and
overweight that's the problem with
appetite
but there's a lot of people that
struggle with appetite like i did never
struggled with being overweight
bulimia nervosa
these people struggle with a
with with something that's spiritually
rooted
i want to show you just the definition
it says an emotional disorder involving
distortion of body image and obsessive
desire to lose weight
in which bouts of extreme overeating are
followed by depression and self-induced
vomiting purging or fasting
it's also known as an eating disorder in
which a large quantity of food is
consumed in a short period of time often
followed by feelings of guilt and shame
it's like benji the world
won't say it
but we as sons and daughters of god this
is a spiritual problem this is not just
a psychological physical problem this is
a spiritual
problem
and this is i found this picture and i
was like wow so you have this thin girl
looking at herself in the mirror but
what she sees in the mirror is not the
truth
it's the illusion that satan is putting
in her mind
satan is the one telling her that
satan's the one that tells somebody god
doesn't love you anymore you've done
this too many times you've gone too far
you've you've grieved the holy spirit
that's satan's voice that's not god's
voice
so this woman
she has been
influenced
by the enemy
here's another lady and you look how
thin this lady is and i'm not saying
being thin is bad it's not a sign of
anorexia but that's what she's dealing
with
she's looking at and that's just a
simple burger and it looks like there
might be some slice of meat on there but
it's not like one of those ones we saw
in that video
and she's got her mouth taped closed
because she's worried about her weight
and look at her how could she work she
could put on 40 pounds and not have to
be worried about her weight
this is called anorexia nervosa and if
you look at the lady that is portrayed
here
that's sad
it's it's tormented
guilt shame
uh
nervousness not understanding confusion
of face
the definition for anorexia is a lack or
loss of appetite for food
as a medical condition they put that in
there as medical because they don't want
you going to the church to get help with
this unfortunately most of our churches
many of our churches don't know how to
deal with that because they don't know
they don't understand that there's a
spiritual cause if i go to the doctor i
don't want to just put in a band-aid on
my leg that just got hacked off in a car
wreck
i mean a band-aid is not going to fix
the problem i want you to fix the root
cause
if i've got cancer don't say well take
this pill to get rid of the pain
what caused the cancer
fix the root
then they say it is an emotional
disorder characterized by an obsessive
desire to lose weight by refusing to eat
scripture says in proverbs
for as a man or a woman thinketh in
their heart so is he
for out of the heart are the issues or
the springs of the life
so the first thing we have to do to gain
victory over appetite or to gain victory
over anorexia or bulimia or whatever is
get the programming
right here first correct what's going on
in the heart and the mind first and the
best way to do that
is by this
if you've been rejected find out how
much god says i've accepted you i love
you with an everlasting love i will
never leave you or forsake you all of a
sudden your day can completely change
and that your image of yourself that the
enemy is putting in front of you
god will pierce through that darkness
he'll say you're my daughter you're my
son
stand up and be who i called you to be
and all of a sudden his victory will
become ours
in revelation chapter 18 verse 1 and 2
it says babylon has fallen for she has
become the habitation of devils remember
there's jerusalem or jerusalem and
babylon jerusalem is the city of god's
people babylon is the city of the
enemy's people
babylon has become the habitation the
dwelling place of devils and the hold of
every foul spirit in a cage of every
unclean and hate-filled bird
when we open the door
to the enemy and he comes in
this is how he begins influencing our
lives so like with what you guys do so
much to share on on the dangers of
hollywood or our video games from the
music industry it opens the door
it opens the door so that enemy can come
in and often when an evil spirit comes
into a life i'm not saying into a person
when it comes into a person's life it
can often bring others with it so maybe
there's a demon of rejection
that the door gets open to because you
were rejected by somebody well that
demon of rejection can bring bitterness
at being rejected it can bring a spirit
called um
lust that tries to fix the rejection
rejection means i don't feel any
dopamine or oxytocin so the devil says
well i can get you to start lusting or
self-abuse or looking at immoral
immorality and all of a sudden you're
feeling that dopamine so the devil's
just bringing all kinds of people to the
party to destroy you
we must inevitably be under the control
of the one or the other of the two great
powers that are contending for the
supremacy of the world
it is not necessary this is what you
were saying for us deliberately to
choose the service of the kingdom of
darkness in order to come under its
dominion
we have only to neglect
to ally ourselves with the kingdom of
light and truth
if we do not cooperate with the heavenly
agencies
satan will take possession of the heart
and make it his abiding place
yeah the bible talks about it or jesus
said if you're not with me
you're against me
and that's what if you're not with
christ then you're automatically
inviting satan in what we don't realize
i've had a lot of people tell me well
i'm not for jesus but i'm not for the
devil i'm just in the middle i'm i'm my
own person
we were born on the devil's side right
it's not we're not standing on neutral
ground and we got to make a choice who
we're going to serve we were born on the
wrong side
with the sentence of death on ourselves
the bible says
when we choose christ we come out from
under that dominion amen amen
that's why jesus came to set the
captives free that's right
this is another article that i really
love
youth instructor 1892
it says jesus pitied and loved not only
those who sought to be obedient and
loving
but those also who were wayward and
perverse
jesus has not changed he is the same
yesterday today and forever
he still loves and pities the airing
seeking to draw them to himself so that
he may give them divine aid
he knows that a demon power is
struggling in every soul
striving for the mastery or the dominion
but jesus came to break the power of
satan and to set the captives free
hallelujah
today he says i stand at the door and
knock
if any man or woman hears my voice
my word and opens the door of their
heart
he promises
i will come into you and sup with you
and they with me
and i want to encourage all of our
listening audience our brothers and
sisters and friends look up these
references in matthew 4 4 and john 6
john chapter 6 verse 27 through 58
because jesus says i'll come into them
and sup with them and eat with them and
for me most of my life i just read that
i was like fine he's coming in to eat
with me what does that mean what are we
eating
look up those verses and do some reading
even if you just take a week and study
just those verses you will be shocked
what the lord will reveal to you will
love it
anyway i i think it's so neat that like
you know there's this constant theme of
food in the bible like it starts over
with uh you know falling because we ate
the wrong piece of food but god places
us in the garden first command you can
eat of any tree of the garden except for
that one and in the end when we get to
heaven what's the first thing we do
amen that's a major part of our
experience with god
amen and so you know this is not a a
beats you up you have to eat only you
know grass and
hate your food
god's created a lot of really wonderful
things and i you know when you when you
learn to eat food that is good for your
body don't you feel good i mean doesn't
it feel good to to you know have a juice
vegetable juice or something you know
and you're just like wow i feel like
great i'm awake and you know you go eat
a bunch of burgers and fries and you're
like
and then we're gonna go to sleep you
know what's weird when you just said
that i thought about there's some foods
that i like the taste of and it may be
whatever vegetarian or vegan
but after i eat them they they feel
great while i'm eating but afterward i
don't feel great but when i sit down and
i eat the way god wants me to i feel
good afterwards i actually feel better
afterward yeah it's more sustaining it's
more long-lasting and and that's just a
that's just a testament god god designed
food for us to enjoy amen
and so i feel like we've kind of ruined
our taste buds with these hyper sweet
foods because you know if you eat um
some candy and then eat some fruit right
behind it you're not even gonna taste it
compared to the candy and
i i started
kind of like a keto diet i was really
strict on it and i'm still doing it but
um that's like very
low sugars low carbohydrates and now
fruit tastes amazing because i don't get
to eat it a lot it's too high in sugar
or whatever but if i eat a banana or
something it's like wow this thing is so
good you can actually bring the
sensitivity back to your sweet taste
buds i had a man that told me that years
ago he said eric he said
fast for a couple of days i fasted you
know it was a little more than five days
not much but a little more than five
days the end of five days when i ate
that first piece of lettuce the lettuce
by itself i was like i put that in my
mouth and i was like and i never knew it
tasted like this it was like all of a
sudden like my brain was like exploding
like wow i didn't know lettuce had this
flavor
but by by going off of all the rich
stuff
all of a sudden it was like that changed
and people can do that they'll go like
on a fruit you know fast for for a week
try that for a week or try doing just
salads or whatever your body can handle
but just by getting rid of all the
processed stuff all of a sudden you'll
find there's flavor there that you never
realize
try the daniel diet you know what gives
meat its flavor
vegetables that's right that's what you
season it with a good form there's so
many different varieties of fruits and
vegetables it's so much to explore and
to taste find out what you like and
don't like but there's like a small
variety of of meats you can season it
all different types of ways but there's
a small variety of meats so just giving
things a try yeah you know yeah opening
up your mind and trying different things
the world has a lot out there for us
so there's a daniel challenge for you
guys out there um just give it a test do
it for 10 days just give yourself 10
days and say i'm gonna eat like i know
god would want me to eat healthy things
things that are good for your body
things that are good for your soul in
the right proportion in the right
proportions and you will see that that
is literally uh it's it's an enjoyable
experience and i believe you'll you'll
find a blessing there so there's a lot
to chew on during this uh uh talk right
here but uh we hope that you guys are
blessed please leave a comment if you
have a question
leave it in the the comment section
below we'd love to try to answer your
questions if you like this video give it
two thumbs up and uh you know thank you
so much for stopping by we hope that
you'll come back again next week
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world
and in 1999 a movie titled the matrix
hit the world stage these stories are
often told and seen over and over again
is it simply just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
you